in accident and emergency they're
prepared for anything
this person potential they've still got
capacity up on amu so you've got loads
of space in quicken darwin
but kovid was a step into the unknown
northwick park hospital in london has
one of the highest coveted death rates
in the country the very first
of thousands of cases came through the
door in the early evening of the 4th of
march this year
it felt like a one-off um and then
within two weeks we were seeing
20 to 30 a day and we doubled we were
doubling at a rate of about
every two to three days and within four
weeks we were seeing
uh 80 to 100 cases a day very very sick
people came in very very quickly
that first wave hit on march the 19th
the hospital was getting more cases
through its front door that it could
deal
with and it was quickly running out of
critical care beds
and so a major incident was declared
it was the first in the country to raise
the alarm
we realized this was this was out of the
bag this was
this was going to come and so very
quickly
we had to change how this hospital was
organized
and then things moved very very fast
indeed okay so
what's the story so i have a 59 year old
gentleman with a four-day history of
increase shortness of breath
we were filling up a ward of with
patients probably every three days
it was something i'd never seen before
it was
incredibly challenging in every way
imaginable
that we knew that the hospital was
becoming overwhelmed we knew that
patients were coming through
and we were in a position where we were
running out of resources
the patient i'm about to meet says he's
lucky to be alive
abdullah buldoki caught covid a few
weeks ago
and it nearly killed him how long have
you been in hospital
today i'm two weeks actually i came here
i was very
very tired you were seriously ill in
this hospital
yes when i arrived this hotel i was i
was
nearly finished coughing a lot
difficulty breathing headache
temperature and tired
franco paulo is a charge nurse at
northwick park
he developed coveted symptoms in
mid-april
i have fever and shortness of breathing
so we went to the hospital
my symptoms is getting worse
i was on the back seat of the of the car
my lips are getting blue
it's really trying to strangle you
at the hospital staff realize the
patient is actually a friend
and colleague i can see their worry in
their face
their sadness i can see some of them
crying also
and when franco doesn't respond to
treatment the decision is made
to put him on a ventilator i told
the consultant let me have a quick word
with my wife with grace
i told my wife i promised to her that
i'll come back
after five weeks in a coma franco beat
the virus
and pulled through i'm happy that
god gave me again a chance to wear again
the uniform
and to help out the people
the staff here have learned a lot about
how to manage this
virus so whole wards have been set aside
left empty in case they're needed and
new drugs are proving effective
there was no specific treatment for
covert until relatively recently
when there's been a few trials so
there's uh the dexamethasone and there's
rem deserving which have uh in our
limited experience
it seems to have changed the landscape
completely where patients who
we thought would need to spend a
prolonged period of time in mechanical
ventilation
seem to get better a lot quicker and it
also stops some people who
we would have previously thought would
require mechanical ventilation
from being committed to intensive care
we've been watching
every single step of the release from
lockdown
and i think it's gone well so far
in the uk i think what really really
underpins
successful release and lockdown is the
testing that's going on
and after two weeks in hospital abdullah
is going home to his family
they brought me back to life really
and i i am very happy
this is the story of one hospital among
thousands
hoping that the feared second wave will
never come
nick martin sky news